okay we've got something else that we
are adding to the YouTube sponsorship
benefits YouTube sponsorship is a beta
program that the david pakman show has
been invited to participate in this
allows you to sponsor the show by
clicking the sponsor button on our
youtube channel homepage or below every
video on our channel it's $4.99 a month
one of the things you get access to is
sponsors only posts and videos on the
community tab so for example sponsors
are able to vote as to which topics we
will cover on the upcoming
pseudo-science miniseries one of the
other benefits that we want to launch
soon for sponsors is custom emojis that
can be used in live chat these are we
can do whatever we want with these they
can be any kind of images that you can
think of they could be political they
could be show related they could maybe
the Pat agreeing with me gif could be
turned into a emoji of some kind
I don't know but we are opening a call
it's an open call for emojis that could
be made part of the permanent offerings
of YouTube sponsorship we're gonna post
the technical requirements for the
images in the video description down
below the video ok we are welcoming all
submissions that meet the tech
requirements and I think what we'll do
Pat yeah is once we get some good ones
we'll do an initial sort of screening we
will allow the full YouTube audience to
vote on which emojis should be made
official and permanent emojis as as part
of the david pakman show channel I'm
hoping none of these emojis are deranged
or embarrassing yeah I mean I think
embarrassing would be fine but certainly
we they need to be work safe I focus the
point right because that's a I don't
know if what the requirements are around
that but check out the description the
requirements down in the video
description
send me your emoji submissions david at
david pakman.com and then we will have
the full audience vote on those very
soon